McDonald's they are taking the toys out
of Appy meals that's right they're
putting books in Happy Meals that sounds
like the worst thing I can possibly
imagine for making them unhappy meals
they're making truly unhappiness for a
limited time McDonald's will distribute
20 million self-published print books
and happy meals to coincide with
National Family Literacy Day also
doesn't sound like a great day ah let's
take a look at the McDonald's restrooms
ah
McDonald's were all four books in print
for Happy Meal customers providing more
than 20 million books to families across
the u.s. throughout the two-week happy
meal books offer families will be able
to enjoy four original books featuring
McDonald's Happy Meal characters of
course each limited-edition book brings
nutrition imagination and play to life
in a fun way so yes these are books that
were made by their PR push their stuff
it's just like the worst kind of all
they're trying to pretend this is about
making kids really disgusting you're
you're a mother what do you think well I
haven't eaten McDonald's in years and
Macmillan does not eating McDonald's my
daughter does not eating McDonald's
either and in fact we taught her when
she was little to say that George Bush
and Ronald McDonald kill people and what
can she read how else will she learn to
read if not three McDonald you know what
they should instead of changing the
prize that goes along with the meal
change the meal get rid of the [ __ ]
poisons yeah and the pink slime in the
wealthy whatever else they're using in
their food I think it's disgusting that
they lure kids in and parents become
susceptible to this and just to shut
their kids up and to save some time take
them to this place it's horrible yeah
it's horrible but but isn't this the
reverse then because you're taking the
toy away and now putting a book yeah but
you're putting a book that has toy
characters in it yes so it basically is
is placating it's rotating somebody out
there and then they're just keep they
were introducing the characters in a
different way so that the characters
will come back
the kids will be familiar with the
characters and want more of the
character right so would you be more
okay with it
with it if these were legit books not
made by McDonald's you know PR company
yeah I mean I I think a kid would enjoy
opening up a happy meal and coming
through worn pieces or maybe the forest
or something yeah yeah you know maybe
Catcher in the Rye get a kid be ready
for the word [ __ ] like that yeah I think
so yeah it's it's the point is the food
though yeah so we're all agreed that the
food the food is just awful but how do
you stop it how do you stop sending kids
to these places whether they're getting
toys or books the food is awful you know
they I don't think the food is so
horrible I've seen the pink slime videos
yeah but they don't form I understand is
that they don't put that in their
hamburgers anymore now it's out for the
last yeah it's yeah the problem is you
know the way we treat that you know beef
and cattle and that's really the real
problem you know I think you know you
get a ham sandwich or a cheeseburger I
think they're pretty much the same thing
right on white bread that's not good for
you and all the buns have a lot of sugar
in there yes I mean they produce things
and you know the mass-produced they do
it in a cheap a cheap cost-efficient way
right you know fried things a lot of
fried things yes on the McNuggets that
which have ingredients in the United
States that are illegal in the Europe
yeah that are partly used to make yoga
mats yes so they have non foodstuffs in
their food judge referred to it as
frankenfood yeah so I don't go for the
chicken nuggets but I don't know I mean
is if you if you take your kid and get
rid of a happy meal every day that's not
go who's feeding their kids like that's
a lot of people do people do its its
associate I cannot look at the obesity
among so it's all God it's so I know and
now that we have Obamacare shouldn't we
be more concerned about everyone's
health because now we're all paying it
together right well we thought we know
what yes I agree we were by the way we
were all paying in before we were people
were going to the emergency yeah I mean
it cost a lot more but it seems like
we're all gonna be in it a little bit
more now isn't it yeah it does certainly
does uh-uh
you know I saw supersize me did you see
it I haven't seen that and I heard
it was really so yeah I mean that's a
guy who ate three meals a day after
McDonald I mean you say she's not
supposed to do that you know so 80 I
mean if you if you had cornflakes three
times a day I'm sure they would have
yeah but you had if you have healthy
food three times a day yeah you had you
know vegetables and salad and grains
yeah protein and that three times a day
would be great right
isn't it just about money we talk about
this whole thing is just about money and
excellent education and all it's hard to
prepare healthy more I don't cook
anymore I really I mean what do you eat
Tom is a really good cook husband but
when he doesn't but when he doesn't cook
I mean I scramble I mean I I used to
cook and I say at the time I said I know
I used to cook alone until my late 30s I
know I used to cook and but I forgot I
mean I really forgot how and now I have
a very thin repertoire you know my
specialty is cheese oh do you still eat
you still eat meat and stuff I do I eat
I haven't eaten beef in a long time yeah
I eat chicken and I eat fish chicken
turkey and fish okay no that's not
certainly a perfect something but that's
something I can't stop eating sushi I
have to keep eating and crab I get pally
crabs do like you have crabs yeah what
are you from what I understand yeah all
right so eat some chicken turnout exhale
and try reading a real book and and see
what happens brought to you by Cooper
comm they've got up to 75% off cat and
dog treats toys and more you can get
another 20% off using code our our the
link is right down below click it and
make your pet happy